sin sorpresas la película francesa titán
de yulia no se alzó con la palma de oro
del festival de cannes 2021 sin
sorpresas porque fue sin duda la cinta
más radical de esta edición una mezcla
de sexo violencia fantasía y horror que
le permitió a giuliano convertirse en la
segunda mujer en toda la historia del
festival de cannes en alzar la palma de
oro 28 años después de jane campion
[Música]
titanes una cinta impecable y
resueltamente monstruosa que provocó
incluso que algunas personas tuvieran
que ser evacuadas de la proyección en
cannes debido a su nivel de violencia yo
creo que es importante poner películas
de género en los festivales como cannes
así es como podremos educar a la gente a
ver otras propuestas y ampliar el
panorama cinematográfico yo también que
es un condición
y el jurado en cannes presidido por el
estadounidense spike lee entregó el gran
premio para dos películas un héroe de
asghar farhadi y compartimento número 6
de yukos manning dos películas también
compartieron el premio del jurado la
rodilla de aed del israelí nadav lapid y
memoria del tailandés apichatpong
weerasethakul la única película filmada
en américa latina' y hablada
parcialmente en español de su lado el
francés leos carax se llevó el galardón
para el mejor director por su comedia
musical
annette que inauguró este certamen que
tradicionalmente se lleva a cabo en el
mes de mayo pero que en 2021 fue
pospuesto a julio en virtud de la crisis
sanitaria
[Música]
la edición 2021 del festival de cannes
se clausuró con la proyección de la
cinta
ss 117 alerta roja en áfrica negra
protagonizada por el galán francés yo
tan mal
[Música]
el punto de vista de la producción
cómo se celebra
boyle país
[Música]